thanks again so maybe start with better
pucker ensue if you lived in California
last year and looked at your you're kind
of back window this could well be what
you saw year of huge blizzards all over
California the biggest of which cause
seventeen billion dollars worth of
damage and actually the first year that
people were really attributing this
stuff to climate change and that's not
kind of scientists saying out that was
the executive team and insurance
companies saying that to 2017 hadn't
been that many much for hurricane
activity for a few years and then we
kind of heard this August 25th
we had the hurricane that hit Houston
hurricane Harvey completely flooded it
second biggest hurricane losses on
record and then going into September we
had who's a three storms borrowing force
the Atlantic at the same time aiming
straight for Florida and then back in
2011 we're at 330 billion dollars worth
of damage we had the most losses ever in
a single year with the big earthquakes
in first of all New Zealand and then in
Japan with the Tohoku earthquake which
was was actually the biggest earthquake
magnitude nine ever recorded in Japan
and of course the tsunami then caused
this the Fukushima nuclear reactor got
hit by the tsunami and exploded causing
huge months of damage and this is
interesting from a modeling perspective
for kind of two reasons the first is it
highlights the fact that with
catastrophes you often get these kind of
compounding effects of the one thing
that you kind of know about the
earthquake
scaling into something that you didn't
predict at all
the nuclear reactor blowing up making
the disaster much much worse the other
thing and I've got this weird Japanese
script on the left is you know you might
think of why on earth would you build a
nuclear reactor right in the middle of
where a tsunami might hit and they
didn't plan it actually the models at
that time said this was a really safe
bit of Japan to be building it but there
was some active research partly from
historical records like this and partly
from some geological sampling that we're
doing that said actually in the 9th
century in it 69 80 there was a almost
identical tsunami that had hit and it
just hadn't been sort of updated in the
models that were used for the nuclear
risk assessment so there's some
interesting kind of elements the data
sets so kind of putting this together
pull from this website that Swiss rehabs
that allow you to do a lot of data query
on this this is what the last sort of 30
40 years of disasters look like and I
think there's there's kind of two things
to really note here one is that losses
aren't insured losses so blue is the
overall losses and then pink is the
fraction that's insured are pretty
steadily increasing and the two worst
years and record of you know occurred
within the last ten years and that's
actually primarily to do not to do
things getting worse but due to lots of
people building very expensive
properties in Florida and California and
places where it's really expensive I
think the other thing to note is that
there's still a considerable gap between
what's insured and what the total losses
is so which is something that you know
there's a sort of resilience gap there
and the final thing is really you know
even when you have these sort of
terrible years and there's very big
record losses insurance companies don't
really go out of business so the
modeling is actually pretty good we kind
of understand the stuff fairly well
but before moving off this just sort of
calling I did you know I'm gonna talk a
lot about losses and dollar amounts and
things there's obviously a huge loss of
life component to this that the models
are also useful but you get different
signals right so 2010 there was a huge
earthquake in Haiti hundreds of
thousands of people lost their lives not
so much economic damage obviously but
everything we're going to talk about is
very much applicable on the kind of
disaster management side as well okay so
so what we do is we have a completely
open source free markets on github
that's a real for anyone to use to do
this kind of modeling and as well as the
software we actually have a community of
practitioners of scientists of users we
have a couple of conferences each year
really the kind of hub thought
leadership and figure out some of this
stuff and we are sort of funded a lot of
gittel of insight from the insurance
reinsurance world but you know these
tools are more broadly applicable than
that okay so that's a bit of context for
the rest of talk I'm going to sort of
focus on four things and we were told
very briefly about insurance it's not
going to be a big insurance talk at all
I'm then going to get into what these
models actually look like because
they're a bit different there's some
interesting aspects of the models
themselves and if I've got time I'll
actually show you how we're using
Jupiter notebooks to try and kind of
communicate some of this stuff and some
of the uncertainties and the models and
then I'm definitely gonna make time for
the fourth point which is some
applications of machine learning they're
sort of emerging around this space and
it's not something we do per se but
we're partnering with different
organizations to kind of look at some of
these applications and I definitely
wanna kind of cover that off ok so very
quickly insurance so properly insurance
you know it's not just houses it's kind
of anything that you can own any sort of
physical structures houses office blocks
hospitals different kind of energy
facilities wind farms you know anything
that you can build and might get worked
by some kind of a disaster then
obviously you want to ensure this stuff
so you have relationship with a an
insurer a sort of AX
Zurich Aviva of this world but actually
what then happens is the risk kind of
gets concentrated in the world of
reinsurers
that's essentially insurance companies
who insure the insurers and that's kind
of from our perspective the interesting
bit because it's those guys that you
know have really a percentage of kind of
all of the say hurricane risk in the
u.s. because they're taking a little bit
of bits of all of these direct insurers
so that's both where the risk gets
concentrated but where you have a lot of
scientists and experts you know really
thinking very deeply about how to
understand and manage this stuff and
then finally we are seeing this some of
this stuff starting transferring to the
capital markets and the big idea there
is that this stuff should really be
completely be correlated with any other
types of risk if there's a big hurricane
there's no reason that the stock market
should be down at the same time so in
theory they should potentially be quite
a kind of cheap efficient way of
managing disasters and of course so what
insurers generally use our actuarial
models write these and for pricing they
use them for figuring out how much money
they need to keep in the bank to pay out
claims and generally these things happen
quite often and they're not that big in
terms of the total amounts lost so
things like fires thrifts accidental
damage at homes you know so typically
these insurance companies have tons and
tons of data you know the last five
years of theft is probably quite a good
predictor of what's gonna happen next
year so you can just build statistical
models and everything works fine
not so good for disaster models these
are quite rare high severity events we
don't have that much theater on them so
you usually have some claims data from
the last 20 years or so there's
historical events maybe 100 years worth
of decent data and you've got scientific
and engineering studies
and research that you can kind of fool
together and his historical claims are
good indicator of future claims maybe
climate change is kind of completely
mixing it up on the on the kind of storm
hurricane side and then there's things
like cyber risks to cyber catastrophes
that the industry is getting increasing
interest in using these techniques to
model and they've never had before right
so it's a pretty open playing field so
how do you do this stuff well you build
structural models you take what you do
know and you build simulations on top of
it so just to sort of reiterate the
problems then with building catastrophe
models so they don't happen very often
or may never have happened before they
have unexpected and severe consequences
we saw the Fukushima reactor blowing up
with the tsunami Hurricane Katrina with
the levees breaking and flooding
flooding it was a very kind of similar
scenario completely unexpected side
effect and the past is not necessarily a
good guide to the future
okay so in terms of the things we
actually build these models for you know
because a lot of this has been driven by
you know where this sort of economic
investment is we have very rich moral
set for North America for Europe some
for the Asia in Japan so you know all
the major kind of natural perils
earthquake cyclone tornadoes windstorm
Hill etc terrorism's are kind of
interesting one because you know on the
one hand putting a one-ton bomb in the
middle of Piccadilly Circus you can
build a physical model of that right
what's more tricky is how do you assign
a probability of that happening in a
given year and there are pooches start
where people use game theory to work out
likelihoods a particular attack moods
they're not totally accepted there's
there's some controversy in that the
other thing that you'll notice and this
is one of the areas where a wisss comes
in is there's a big blank area over
Africa there's a big blank area for a
lot of the developing world in Asia and
there isn't really the funding to build
these super detailed commercial models
but they're also often is expertise in
local universities or within the
government's there so part of the
benefit of having these open source
tools is it allows you to quickly build
something that at least is a sort of you
know first pass at understanding and
managing the risk that can then develop
and become more sophisticated over time
okay so kind of digging in a little bit
more then to what these models look like
so on the left hand side we start with
the event set and this is this is really
where the science comes in so for a
windstorm model typically you'd run a
sort of global circulation model on a
big supercomputer you know you get a few
weeks on one of those you generate
millions and millions of years of
possible events and then you boil it
down into something that's a bit more
manageable and that you could actually
run on you know a reasonable kind of
business server so maybe a you know
you'd end up with a few hundred thousand
cent characteristic events for each of
those you've then got a detailed hazard
map so you'd actually grid up whatever
area you're looking at and then have
four windstorm so it would be a peak
wind speed over some time period first
quick would be some measure of shaking
for flood it would be a you know a depth
or maximum depth of water coming down
from the top then you've got exposure
data so what are you actually modeling
again so the inventory of buildings
their characteristics how much they're
worth where exactly are they you have
tools to refine that Deana so J kudos to
accurately please it
and then you stick this together to
actually understand the likely damage so
the vulnerability is the other bit that
goes into the model and this is really
the sort of engineering expertise so you
know if I have a two-story building it's
made of wood with a certain type of roof
and I blew a ninety Marlin or wind on it
what's the kind of probability
distribution of it's likely kind of
failure modes so you do that for all the
locations you're interested in for all
of the event sets you have a financial
model that implies the kind of insurance
terms and conditions and then you get
some metrics out
you can make decisions with I'm kind of
digging inside a bit more so the thing
comes out of these models that the
insurance company or the kind of risk
manager any government really cares
about is you know up the y-axis what
level of loss am I going to experience
and the return period so you know 1 over
the probability of occurring in a
different in any given year and it's
actually sort of calling out a few
interesting features of the data on the
charts on the left hand side you've got
the kind of black square and that's your
actual experience so as an insurance
company you've probably got 20 years of
actual real detailed data that tells you
stuff the big blue box then is their
hundred odd years of historical stuff
you know the storm record so you know
you can actually you can use that in a
in a kind of reasonable way but then we
not beyond a hundred years and this is
actually like if the regulation or an
insurance company it's actually the one
on two hundred year number that tells
them how much they need to keep in the
bank so that they don't go out of
business and we just don't have any data
there it's you know it's the opinion of
the modeler and we've got three models
here Ford C imperil and you know you
often get wildly different opinions on
this risk
so kind of digging a little bit more
into kind of how these are put together
so the hazard model the stochastic
tracks and the footprint that we saw on
the last slide you know you've got some
historical data you've got some
scientific models so you know for a
windstorm you actually have the fluid
dynamics laws that you can use to sort
of simulate this stuff we've got the
vulnerability data which might be actual
claims experience what happened over the
last 15 20 years
you also have engineering studies and
there are labs where you build little
houses and shake them a lot or blow lots
of wind up them and you just see what
happens so there is empirical data that
you can use there but the kind of
interesting bit is what happens when you
stick the two of those together is it at
all feasible and that's where the kind
of expert judgement or secret sauce
comes in because the castra models that
pop at the end people sale to insurance
companies gave you know credible losses
and people accept them but there's this
kind of black box calibration stage that
it's that there's not much kind of
visibility into which is a bit that the
sort of users worry about quite a lot
okay so a little bit on the technology
and how this stuff is actually kind of
deployed so this is what the insurance
world's been doing for the last 20 years
so you've got your scientists they use
C++ for trying are a bunch of tools to
actually use modeling money build the
data sets which then get we're still in
dotnet Micra C or sequel server world in
terms of the applications and then for
the actual reporting Excel sequel server
that's what these analysts like to use
and there I've got a good bit of Gorilla
Tape there showing how these things are
stuck together I asked is not bad
analogy because
it's not pretty but it works this has
been the sort of backbone of the
insurance market for quite a long time
and if you want to unpick it and tidy it
up it's quite difficult and quite
painful so we're taking a slightly
different tack and using all the kind of
wonderful data science tools which now
exist and the key idea is to write at
the heart of that we have a Python
package so we actually have C++
components that do this or a heavy
lifting so the millions of simulated
events and location loss events that we
need to do and then we wrap that in a
Python layer and that's published on PI
PI's it's nice and easy to install and
that gives a kind of nice way of using
the components either from the command
line in a linux environment or plugged
into other Python tools so that you know
as a model developer maybe you don't
actually need much else you can just
write Python code on top of that and I'm
always good on the enterprise side then
you know the stuff doesn't need to be
run at scale in a business so Django
celery docker pretty standard toolkit
works very well and then from the user
perspective we're on a bit of a mission
to get the catastrophe modeling world on
to Jupiter because it's just such good
fit you know people are trying to
understand and communicate complex
models and reasoning with uncertainty in
the lost distributions and it's just
painful with spreadsheets and usually
ends up with copious amounts of
documentation so we're trying to through
examples and training really push
Jupiter in these applications and then
we're doing some pretty interesting work
on the how we actually really scale this
stuff out so some of the things we're
looking at this year is deploying the
models and a kubernetes environment and
how it integrates with things like spark
and the big data player
forms or some of the declawed options
and we can't be too prescriptive with
this because the organization's we work
with usually have defined some kind of
bigger strategy on how they want to run
their big clusters of computers and we
want to fit class three models into that
rather than doing something different
okay how we doing for time with sounds
okay so I'm going to skip over the
jupiter bit to make sure that i have
time for machine learning bits so as i
said one of the so we provide certain
source software but we also have a
community of users so one of the values
of oasis is that if there's interesting
ideas that are applicable in the space
we can connect people up with the right
people to actually use the stuff and if
appropriate we also have these stuff you
know we have api etc deployed in these
organizations so it's a very easy way of
getting new models or analytics being
used in the insurance market so to give
a couple of examples
Rhonda's I've got two case studies who
are with partners were working with who
using machine learning and first please
is Norma it's called ensure data and I
mentioned that the exposure data that
you're feeding into the system is really
critical rubbish and you know no matter
how good your actual risk model is the
results are going to be new use so
they've got on the left-hand side you've
got a pretty sort of big error in the
risk where you've duplicated it and it's
just in the wrong place so from a flood
perspective you know if it's one point
three kilometers away that could be on
top of a hill versus right in the
floodplain so you know huge amount to
in the risk so that's pretty crude the
middle one is a bit more subtle where
know if you've got a hoax and you don't
know much about it apart from its metre
word it's got two stories you know but a
lot long is but actually just the fact
that the entrance to the building the
mean door is three or four feet off the
ground as opposed to it surface level
again can make actually quite a big
difference to the risk and similarly if
you know it's on sloping ground so the
entrance was you know three or four
meters above the sort of centroid of the
building again it could change the
profile pretty significantly and they've
done a bunch of case studies still a
somewhat manual process in a minute and
they're sort of seen this 20 to 100
percent impact you know and that's for
an insurance company a huge that's you
know they need to keep twenty one
hundred percent more money in the bank
to cover potential losses so this is
kind of what they're actually trying to
order me if they want to you know scrip
pictures of buildings and then classify
it so they want to pick out features I
want to pick up where the door is they
want to try and measure you know how
high some of these features are and
really check or validate the data that
they have and they're using neural
networks in tenth floor and Amazon Sage
maker to try and automate some of these
processes and they say it's pretty hard
so the first days choices are pretty
variable you know even the number of
windows the configuration of doors
windows it's not like a face where
you've got nose charging the noise and
roughly the same place so it makes it
the classification of that not much more
challenging and then of course there's
image quality you know it you might have
something that works well if it's a
completely straight on well lit image
you're working with but in the data
they've got there's often obstructions
lighting the buildings are slightly
offset all of which really complicates
the problem
so that's a bit of a work in progress
the next company as an Australian
company and they're actually using
machine learning to kind of build models
to replace some of the expert judgment
that goes in and as an example of that
I've picked out how they act and sort of
seasonally forecast hurricane activity
and their thinking was so we've got this
plot of sea surface temperatures and
climate scientists pick out features of
these that they knew based a lot of
their predictive power on so a good
example is the Southern Oscillation
which is the difference in sea surface
temperature between Tahiti and somewhere
in Australia which will come back to me
and that's actually a really good
predictor of El Nino La Nina years and
hence things like hurricane activities
that are related to that and so they've
sort of thought well hang on we don't
need to just restrict ourselves to these
small set of kind of predictors we can
treat it like an image and use all of
these sort of image processing and
classification tool kits to come up with
a whole bunch of different classifiers
that might be useful so use unsupervised
learning to create a bunch of these
classifiers which they correlate against
kind of observed patterns and then
actually use that to build sort of
Bayesian predictors of what hurricane
frequencies might be sitting inside a
minute a bit more this is what these
guys produce sort of going into the
hurricane season so early June they've
got a kind of prior distribution of how
many and storms how many hurricanes
how many major hurricanes they think
it's going to come through and this is a
pretty competitive space actually
there's a whole bunch of
teams around the world who released
these hurricane activity forecasts and
really care about getting the market and
I think last year these guys actually
came first you know which is pretty cool
to see these kind of algorithms actually
working so just to wrap up then it's
pretty important discipline for kind of
doing this resilience modeling
especially when things are moving
climate change migrations of property
and people it is a quite established
discipline there's lots of techniques
there's lots of expertise but loads of
challenges and lots of potential
applications of some of these sort of
new data science techniques and it's
very right for innovation and you know
as a framework in the community
Oasis can really help get some of these
new ideas kind of into the industry I'll
take some questions a sec but just to
wrap up we are looking for a Python
developer so if this kind of seems
pretty exciting to anyone sort of
combining science stuff with Python
development and working with some pretty
smart people in the market come and talk
to me and similarly if this chimes with
things you're potentially doing maybe in
a completely different field again super
interested in kind of figuring out some
more collaborators in this space so
that's the end of the talk any questions
[Applause]
mmm-hmm I mean it's not my total area of
expertise but I think that's kind of
what do we ask guys are doing so there's
obviously a huge scientific community
who do a lot of research trying to
figure out those variables the sort of
scientific investigation but there is
potential for these more data driven
approaches that don't necessarily seem
to have immediate physical basis to be
very useful increasing the the kind of
skill of these models
yeah absolutely I mean oh sorry the
question was are insurance companies
using kind of their own data and their
own claims data to feed into the models
and yeah absolutely I mean if your AXA
you knew more about French wind storm
damage than anywhere else in the world I
mean that's very valuable commercial
information so they have teams who are
basically combining the data sets they
have internally to sort of tweak the
models and from a technology perspective
that's you know historically the models
have actually been very hard to kind of
play about with the sort of next
generation is sort of opening up much
more to like people to kind of change
any of the assumptions underlying them
the yeah but it's a it's a kind of
commercial advantage I guess yep really
good thought thank you question what is
the space what's the spatial resolution
of the basis and does that change and is
the same for different parameters so we
don't build models per se so the
spiritual resolution could be anything
really you actually see a huge
variability between something like a
flood model where it can actually make a
huge difference you know even sort of
ten meters away because it could be an
ingredient the soil conditions could be
extremely different so you get high
resolution flood models that in some
cases good on to two or three meters on
the other hand something like a wind
model there's no real point in doing
that because you know wind storm is
quite uniform over the scale of
kilometers so you have a much sort of
quarter grid the other thing that's
quite sort of interesting from a
modeling perspective is if you ask sort
of research scientists to sort of build
hazard fields they're really interested
in hazards so they'll build you a kind
of uniform grid and pick out all the
features of it
but actually from a risk modeling
perspective you don't really care you
want lots and lots of data in the middle
of cities or where there's lots of high
value factories or whatever and actually
in the middle of desert or whatever you
need actually new data so you have sort
of variable resolution grades that are
optimized for risk as opposed to
understanding the sort of hazard
[Applause]